hey guys welcome to another quick video
this is motion science and I'm Cameron
and today I'm going to talk very briefly
about 3d lights and After Effects let's
face it 3d lights and After Effects are
not the easiest to control and so what
I'm gonna show you is a trick to easily
lighting your scenes okay so let's start
by switching into a to view scene and
I'll go up here to layer new light and
I'll add a spotlight and I'll keep it to
the default settings and there we go
there's the first light in the scene I'm
gonna pull it back on the z-axis bring
it up back a little more and you can see
here this is already the beginning of
our problem it's just difficult to
really light as seen in After Effects
the point of interest the position it's
all kind of a mess so so if I bring this
light back further than Z you can see
right here I'm already losing the
position controls and from here on out
I'm going to zoom out find the controls
and it's just kind of a mess so my
solution to this is to add another new
camera and this camera I'm gonna call
light view I'm going to change it to a
two node camera and click OK so in this
view I'll keep it on camera one but for
this view I will switch to light view
I'm also going to turn on the ambient
light to fill in the scene and here's
the trick I'm going to open up the
spotlight the transform controls so I
can see point of interest and position
and I'm gonna do the same for the light
view camera okay so what I'm gonna do
now is I'm going to option-click or
alt-click on the point of interest of
the spotlight pick whip it to the
point of interest of the light view
camera and then option or alt-click on
the position of the spotlight pick whip
it to the position of the camera and I'm
going to go ahead and activate my camera
control and watch what happens to the
light over here as I move the camera it
controls the light over here so I'll do
is I'll zoom in and now you can really
see the shadows here I can even orbit
the camera to control the point of
interest of the light hopefully you can
see what I'm doing here
and that's it it's super easy so by
looking through this light view camera
I'm controlling the point of interest in
the position of the light over here to
light my scene and that's it for my tip
of the week I hope you learned something
new
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science